Nina has come home to Darkness
earlier this year her apartment was
damaged by shrapnel now she's the victim
of a power cut
the electricity has been off for four
hours she's got no heating she can't
cook food
and winter is coming
over
foreign
but Nina is unbowed a fierce proud
Optimist yeah
but even in this resilient country
bravado does butt against cruel reality
Ukraine has to ration its electricity
and that creates misery
is a teacher with a young family and she
is desperately anxious
in our house we haven't got electric
cooker so I've got a little child I
can't cook feed him
it's very bad I can't walk because I
walk my work is online I work online I I
need electricity but I haven't so at the
end of this month I hope I will I can
earn money to buy food for my family
the traffic lights still work but the
streets are dark light is precious here
foreign
[Music]
and here's why Russia has spent a week
attacking power stations like this one
in Kiev
around a third of Ukraine's power
generation has been damaged
the government says people must use less
electricity and so the lights are turned
out
these power Cuts come without any
warning a couple of minutes ago that
block was lit up now the only sources of
light are coming from torches candles
and people's mobile phones and the other
problem that the residents there face is
that their heating is run by electricity
and temperatures here are dipping
in this block the residents have clubbed
together to buy a generator they'll
probably need more of them they've also
bought wood burning stoves Sergey says
he won't be driven out how long can you
keep going like this
is
it is easy to become blase about this
tenacity but the people of Ukraine are
being pushed and tested every day
they do cope they are proud but daily
life here can be exhausting Adam Parsons
Sky News Keith